This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Scenti Mental. Acquare the competences
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是人类制作。您是否有意愿去做出真正的改变？LaCite学院为您提供“依赖与心理健康”课程。获取相关能力
essential to accompany and support the people confronted to the challenges. Construise a career enrichicent to service of the community francophone
对于陪伴和支持面临挑战的人们至关重要。建立一份丰富的职业生涯，服务于法语社区
of all the country. Don't know the Swin'Alice in French, it's possible with the CIT. Visit CollageLac.C.
遍布全国。想用法语学习Swin'Alice吗？通过CIT可以实现。请访问CollageLac.C。
D.M.C. a initiative of the chief of the Consortium National of Formation in Health, supported by Santa Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up.
D.M.C.是国家健康培训联盟负责人发起的一项倡议，由加拿大卫生部支持。那些眼睛里什么都没有。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。邪恶，醒醒。
I'm the woman that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive.
我是那个目睹了Crevette和DePippo谋杀案的人。Anthony DePippo没有表现出任何悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得泰然自若。我说，我没有罪。我会把真相带进坟墓。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Bone Valley》中的《Devil's Quarry》。快乐是必不可少的，但它也难以捉摸。
But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbe is presented by CVS.
但现在，有一种新的、令人兴奋的方式来开启您通往更快乐生活的旅程。《Joy 101》。这是一个由我，Hoda Kotby主持的新播客。如果您渴望获得灵感来最大化您的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的广播聊天。打开您免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Joy 101》并立即收听。《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》由CVS赞助。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine, just honest conversations about what it means to be alive.
每个人都视我为一名足球运动员，但首先，我是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何处理问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的，只是关于活着的意义的诚实对话。
I'm Javier El Chicharito Hernandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got like so much more to do. Like Prince, he dropped like 30 albums. We dropped like five right now. That's the rate we got to be going.
我是Javier El Chicharito Hernandez，请在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learning to Be Human》。六月是黑人音乐月，在《Drink Chams》播客中，我们正在与文化界最热门的人物交谈，比如Sway Lee。你意识到你有多传奇了吗？我很感激。我看到了，但我心想，伙计，我还有很多事情要做。就像Prince，他发行了大约30张专辑。我们现在才发行了五张。这就是我们必须达到的速度。
Yeah, that's a good attitude. No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations. Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Jemis Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here. Back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, I'm back with another bonus episode. I know two in, how long has it been? Two in two weeks. What is that all about? But I thought, why not? It's my podcast. And I want to talk about this topic because I think it is the perfect candidate for some debunking and some fact-checking, which you guys know we love to do on these, like, smaller episodes. Our bonus episodes, for those of you who may not know, are basically just bite-sized 20-minute eps where we break down a popular psychology term, psychology concept that is generally
是的，那是一个很好的态度。无论什么时代，《Drink Chams》都会为您带来最大牌的人物和最直白的对话。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听来自Black Effect Podcast Network的《Drink Chams》。大家好。我是Jemis Spike，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个我们探讨20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴有你们在这里。回到另一集，我们来剖析20多岁的心理。今天，我带着另一集奖励剧集回来了。我知道两周内两集，这是怎么回事？但我心想，为什么不呢？这是我的播客。我想谈谈这个话题，因为我认为它是进行一些揭秘和事实核查的完美候选者，你们知道我们喜欢在这些较短的剧集中这样做。对于那些可能不知道的人，我们的奖励剧集基本上就是20分钟的短小精悍的剧集，我们会在其中剖析一个流行的心理学术语、心理学概念，这些概念通常
quite misunderstood, but which, you know, we don't have all the time in the world to do a full episode on it, but I still feel like having the right information about it is important. And today, we have possibly our biggest concept yet in this mini-series. We are talking about the psychology of dopamine. Yeah, dopamine. If there was like a pop star, celebrity, royal figure amongst neurotransmitters or even like amongst psychology concepts, it would be dopamine. I genuinely think I've had this discussion that if you asked somebody to name a
相当被误解，但是，你知道，我们没有全世界的时间来做一整集关于它的内容，但我仍然觉得拥有关于它的正确信息很重要。今天，我们在这个迷你系列中拥有可能是我们最大的概念。我们正在谈论多巴胺的心理学。是的，多巴胺。如果神经递质中，甚至心理学概念中有一个流行歌星、名人、皇室人物，那一定是多巴胺。我真心认为我进行过这样的讨论，如果你让某人说出一个
psychology term or a psychology concept, like dopamine would be up there with one that a lot of people would probably say or would probably know alongside things like attachment style or like Pavlov studies. It's just dopamine is one of those terms that like the moment you mention it, it gives you an air of legitimacy. It gives whatever you're saying a sense of importance and that it's factual. You know, this thing released is dopamine. Therefore it must be addictive. It must be motivated. It must be motivational. It must influence your behavior. It must be good for you, bad for you. It might end up controlling you. The thing is, what I've come to realize is that our fundamental and very basic understanding of dopamine is wrong. Maybe not, maybe not wrong. It's simplistic. It lacks a lot of
心理学术语或心理学概念，多巴胺会和许多人可能会说出或可能知道的术语并列，比如依恋类型或巴甫洛夫研究。多巴胺就是那种你一提到它，它就会给你一种合法性的术语。它给你所说的任何事情一种重要感，并且它是事实。你知道，这个东西释放了多巴胺。因此它一定是令人上瘾的。它一定是激励性的。它一定能影响你的行为。它一定对你有好处，对你有坏处。它最终可能会控制你。问题是，我意识到的是，我们对多巴胺的基本和非常基础的理解是错误的。也许不是，也许不是错误的。它是简单化的。它缺乏很多
detail. Dopamine is traditionally seen as the thing that makes us happy and brings us pleasure. It's why we like chocolate. It's why we like sex, drugs, gambling, all those things. But it is much, much more layered than that. And I think when you actually understand when dopamine is released in your brain, why and its role in motivation, in anticipation, movement, how it works differently in different areas of the brain and of the body, you can actually use the term properly and use it in reference to your own brain and behavior accurately. So let's get into it. I love starting these episodes with a bit of history. I feel like if I was ever going to do another podcast, it would definitely be on the history of psychology,
细节。多巴胺传统上被视为让我们快乐并带来快乐的东西。这就是为什么我们喜欢巧克力。这就是为什么我们喜欢性、毒品、赌博，所有这些事情。但它比那要复杂得多，多得多。我认为当你真正理解多巴胺何时在你的大脑中释放，为什么以及它在动机、预期、运动中的作用，它如何在不同的大脑区域和身体区域以不同方式工作时，你就可以正确地使用这个术语，并准确地参考你自己的大脑和行为。所以让我们开始吧。我喜欢以一点历史来开始这些剧集。我觉得如果我还要做另一个播客，那肯定会是关于心理学历史的，
or like the scientific history of certain concepts that we take for granted for, because it is so fascinating and dopamine is no different. The history behind this is just interesting. The man who allegedly first pinpointed this fantastic little, neurochemical or neurotransmitter and its role in the brain was a Swedish man called Arvid Carlson. He actually went on to win the Nobel Peace Prize for his role in synthesizing dopamine to treat Parkinson's, to treat depression, to treat post-stroke fatigue, to name a few things. But here's the secret history for you, whilst he may have gotten all of the credit,
或者像我们认为理所当然的某些概念的科学历史，因为它太迷人了，多巴胺也不例外。这背后的历史非常有趣。据称第一个精确定位这个奇妙的小神经化学物质或神经递质及其在大脑中作用的人是一位名叫Arvid Carlson的瑞典人。他后来因在合成多巴胺以治疗帕金森病、治疗抑郁症、治疗中风后疲劳等方面的贡献而获得了诺贝尔奖。但这里有一个秘密历史给你们，虽然他可能获得了所有的荣誉，
and he definitely did do some fantastic, incredible work in his lifetime. The first, person to actually demonstrate the presence of dopamine in the brain was a woman. Her name was Catherine Montague. She published her findings. Her findings that basically were like, dopamine is real. I have found it. Here it is. She published those findings six months before Carlson did. And, you know, she wrote for the first time conclusively about this tiny chemical that is only produced by 0.0000000005% of all brain cells, but seemingly had, an excessive influence on behavior. Dopamine, like before Catherine's research, because let's give her the credit here, was kind of like a bigfoot lock nest monster kind of mystery to the psychology
而且他一生中确实做了一些非常棒、令人难以置信的工作。第一个真正证明大脑中存在多巴胺的人是一位女性。她的名字叫Catherine Montague。她发表了她的发现。她的发现基本上是说，多巴胺是真实的。我发现了它。它在这里。她在Carlson发表之前六个月就发表了这些发现。而且，你知道，她第一次确凿地写到了这种微小的化学物质，它仅由所有脑细胞的0.0000000005%产生，但似乎对行为有过度影响。多巴胺，在Catherine的研究之前，因为让我们在这里给她应有的荣誉，对心理学和神经科学界来说有点像大脚怪或尼斯湖水怪那样的谜团，
and neuroscience community, like maybe a little bit more serious. Like they knew it existed. They knew there was some interaction with other hormones like adrenaline that was going on, but it was only in the 50s that the mystery and the role of dopamine in the central nervous system was revealed. And it's, you know, gone on to be probably, this is crazy to say, but like the most famous neurotransmitter. Now, when the release of dopamine is triggered, it acts really, really fast. And it acts on different zone sites across the brain and body to make us do things that we think are helpful. And the reason there is such a fuss around dopamine is because it drives so many of our behaviors as humans, even though our body and our brain doesn't necessarily make that much of it.
就像稍微严肃一点。就像他们知道它存在。他们知道它与其他激素（如肾上腺素）之间存在某种相互作用，但直到50年代，多巴胺在中枢神经系统中的谜团和作用才被揭示。而且，你知道，它已经成为可能，说出来很疯狂，但就像最著名的神经递质。现在，当多巴胺的释放被触发时，它作用得非常非常快。它作用于大脑和身体的各个区域，让我们做我们认为有帮助的事情。之所以围绕多巴胺有这么大的动静，是因为它驱动了我们人类的许多行为，尽管我们的身体和大脑并不一定产生那么多。
This is where we have to tackle, I think, the first big myth about the psychology of dopamine, and that is that dopamine is what makes you happy. It is the pleasure hormone. It is the pleasure neurochemical. this idea first emerged from some really early research back in the 70s and 80s that showed dopamine producing regions and dopamine neurons lighting up in response to the promise of reward. Promise being the key word. This kind of led the researchers who were in charge of this study to prematurely assume that
这就是我认为我们必须解决关于多巴胺心理学的第一个大误区的地方，那就是多巴胺是让你快乐的东西。它是快乐激素。它是快乐神经化学物质。这个想法最初出现在70年代和80年代的一些非常早期的研究中，这些研究显示多巴胺产生区域和多巴胺神经元在响应奖励承诺时亮起。承诺是关键词。这导致负责这项研究的研究人员过早地假设
this meant that dopamine was why certain things felt good. and therefore why we felt good and therefore played a big role in our happiness. This we now know is actually false. It isn't what makes us feel pleasure. It's what allows us to forecast or predict or imagine how good pleasure can and will feel, therefore making us chase after it. Its role is in craving and anticipating. It is the do more of that.
这意味着多巴胺是某些事情感觉良好的原因。因此，为什么我们感觉良好，因此在我们的幸福中发挥了重要作用。我们现在知道这实际上是错误的。它不是让我们感到快乐的东西。它是让我们预测、预见或想象快乐可以且将会感觉有多好，从而让我们去追逐它。它的作用在于渴望和预期。它是“多做点那个”
chemical. As one article from the new philosopher puts it, dopamine spikes when we anticipate something exciting or pleasurable happening and it dips when the experience comes about. So dopamine, it's really present. It happens in the lead up to something. And that is why it's actually critical, not for happiness, but for motivation. Rats, for example, who have depleted dopamine levels don't work as hard to get food. They just can't be bothered compared to normal rats. rats. Super high dopogenic people, like people who have a lot of dopamine on the other hand are the types who you meet who are forever planning. They have a new business, a new scheme, a new partner, and you need, like, they've always got something that they want to do. They're never at rest.
化学物质。正如《New Philosopher》的一篇文章所言，当我们预期某件令人兴奋或愉快的事情发生时，多巴胺会激增，而当体验真正到来时，它会下降。所以多巴胺，它确实存在。它发生在某事发生之前。这就是为什么它实际上至关重要，不是为了幸福，而是为了动机。例如，多巴胺水平耗尽的老鼠工作起来不如正常老鼠努力去获取食物。与正常老鼠相比，它们就是懒得动。另一方面，多巴胺水平极高的人，就像那些你遇到的永远在计划的人。他们有一个新生意、一个新计划、一个新伴侣，你需要，就像，他们总是有他们想做的事情。他们从不休息。
They're always seeking the next thing. They are living from one dopamine high to the next. Now, are those people necessarily happier than most people, though? No, even though they have more dopamine per se, or we assume they do, the studies would say they do, it's serotonin that gives us that stable mood and it's dopamine that pushes us to achieve and gain and have things that we think will give us happiness, that we think will give us stability, but are probably quite shallow because they only work to make us want more and more and more and to get slight reward and to experience the high of anticipation followed by the crash, I think, a lot of us are familiar with. When we obtain the thing, we obtain the object of our desire,
他们总是寻求下一件事。他们从一个多巴胺高潮活到下一个。那么，这些人一定比大多数人更快乐吗？不，即使他们本身有更多的多巴胺，或者我们假设他们有，研究会说他们有，是血清素给了我们稳定的情绪，而多巴胺推动我们去实现、获得和拥有我们认为会给我们带来幸福、我们认为会给我们带来稳定的东西，但这些东西可能相当肤浅，因为它们只会让我们想要更多、更多、更多，并获得轻微的奖励，并体验预期的快感，随后是崩溃，我想，我们很多人都很熟悉。当我们获得那个东西，我们获得我们欲望的对象时，
and we find that it's actually not that satisfying. The best way I like to describe this or at least imagine this for myself is shopping, particularly people who really cover an item who are like really pursuing a specific piece or a specific watch or they're always buying clothes, thinking this will be the thing that makes them happy, only to find that when they have it, in their possession, they've bought it, they've got it, nothing much about their baseline happiness changes because they're confusing a dopamine hit, which is meant to be motivational with long-term contentment. Dopamine is short-term, not long-term. This is why dopamine is heavily implicated in literature and in research around addiction. It drives us to fulfill an
我们发现它实际上并没有那么令人满意。我喜欢描述这一点或至少为自己想象这一点的方式是购物，特别是那些真正渴望一件商品的人，他们就像真的在追求一件特定的单品或一块特定的手表，或者他们总是买衣服，认为这将是让他们快乐的东西，结果却发现当他们拥有它时，在他们手中，他们买了它，他们得到了它，他们的基准幸福感并没有太大变化，因为他们把多巴胺冲击（本意是激励性的）与长期满足感混淆了。多巴胺是短期的，不是长期的。这就是为什么多巴胺在关于成瘾的文献和研究中被大量提及。它驱动我们去满足一个
immediate desire only to fulfill our expectations, meaning that it will keep leading us back to drugs, back to gambling, back to nicotine, sugary food, poor financial decisions, whatever your vice is, because it knows these are the fastest pathways to anticipation fulfillment. There's an amazing 2005 study that discusses this, and it talks about how dopamine actually also has a secondary role in attention, meaning people with disrupted dopamine levels or systems, find it hard to physically look away, physically ignore or avoid what they desire. Hence why this neurochemical is so powerful in addiction and getting hooked to things, because the things that it's leading us back to are the things that are going to give us immediate reward,
即时欲望，只是为了满足我们的期望，这意味着它会不断引导我们回到毒品、回到赌博、回到尼古丁、含糖食物、糟糕的财务决策，无论你的恶习是什么，因为它知道这些是通往预期满足的最快途径。有一项2005年的惊人研究讨论了这一点，它谈到了多巴胺实际上在注意力中也有次要作用，这意味着多巴胺水平或系统紊乱的人，发现很难在身体上移开视线，在身体上忽视或避免他们渴望的东西。因此，为什么这种神经化学物质在成瘾和对事物上瘾方面如此强大，因为它引导我们回到的东西是那些将给我们带来即时奖励的东西，
meaning that the anticipation is going to be greater, meaning that this object is going to be more motivational. So that's really what's happening. Now, of course, when we're depressed, when we're in a rut, when we're just like stuck and pessimistic about life, a dopamine deficiency definitely may play into this because we can't motivate ourselves to do or to want anything, including the things we know may help. We can't motivate ourselves to strive. We don't have any ambition.
这意味着预期会更大，意味着这个对象会更具激励性。所以这才是真正发生的事情。当然，当我们抑郁时，当我们陷入困境时，当我们只是对生活感到停滞和悲观时，多巴胺缺乏肯定可能在其中发挥作用，因为我们无法激励自己去做或想要任何事情，包括我们知道可能有帮助的事情。我们无法激励自己去奋斗。我们没有任何野心。
We don't have any vision that we could change, that life could get better. So it does definitely play a role in unhappiness in that it, If we don't have enough dopamine, right? If our dopamine levels are depleted, it's going to feel difficult to want or desire or anticipate anything. But a lack of dopamine alone is not why we are unhappy on a deep level. Dopamine is not, it's not about, it's not the happiness hormone. It's not the happiness chemical. It's the motivational chemical.
我们没有任何愿景认为我们可以改变，认为生活可以变得更好。所以它确实在不快乐中发挥了作用，因为，如果我们没有足够的多巴胺，对吧？如果我们的多巴胺水平耗尽了，想要、渴望或预期任何事情都会感觉很困难。但仅仅缺乏多巴胺并不是我们在深层面上不快乐的原因。多巴胺不是，它不是关于，它不是快乐激素。它不是快乐化学物质。它是动机化学物质。
So here's the second function that dopamine is heavily responsible for. And it's probably one, you don't. hear much about online or in discussions about dopamine, like on TikTok or Instagram or wherever. It's movement. Dopamine acts on the basal ganglia. Again, deep in our brain. Deep in our brain, that's where a lot of our dopamine producing cells are. Dopamine acts on the basal ganglia to stimulate movement to help us to wreck our muscles, to control our nerve cells, our body. The reason we know it's so vital just for our body's ability to move itself, is because of diseases like Parkinson's.
所以这是多巴胺负责的第二个功能。这可能是一个你在线上或关于多巴胺的讨论中（比如在TikTok或Instagram或任何地方）听不到太多的功能。它是运动。多巴胺作用于基底神经节。同样，在我们大脑深处。在我们大脑深处，那是我们许多多巴胺产生细胞所在的地方。多巴胺作用于基底神经节以刺激运动，帮助我们控制肌肉，控制我们的神经细胞，我们的身体。我们知道它对我们身体自身运动的能力如此重要，是因为像帕金森病这样的疾病。
The progressive neurological disorder, you probably know it from Michael J. Fox, it causes tremors, muscle stiffness, confusion. Dopamine and Parkinson's have a long history. And we now know that a lot of the reason why the Parkinson's symptoms show up is because of a lack of dopamine. Basically, Parkinson's is caused by the progressive death of dopamine-producing cells in the substantia nigra. Deep in the brain.
这种进行性神经系统疾病，你可能从Michael J. Fox那里知道它，它会导致震颤、肌肉僵硬、混乱。多巴胺和帕金森病有着悠久的历史。我们现在知道，帕金森症状出现的大部分原因是因为缺乏多巴胺。基本上，帕金森病是由黑质中多巴胺产生细胞的进行性死亡引起的。在大脑深处。
Literally the cells that could produce this vital chemical die. And the reason we don't know, we don't know why that happens. Like they have some, there's all these theories, right? Genetics obviously plays a big role in it, exposure to certain chemicals also.
字面上，那些能产生这种重要化学物质的细胞死亡了。我们不知道原因，我们不知道为什么会发生这种情况。就像他们有一些，有所有这些理论，对吧？遗传显然在其中发挥了很大作用，接触某些化学物质也是。
But we don't really know why it's just those cells that die off. And when they do, it means that less dopamine is available. And that seems to be directly correlated to this reduction in the ability to control deliberate or unconscious and conscious movement to just get our body to do what we want it to do. People with Parkinson's will talk about wanting, like say for example, you have like a cup of juice, I don't know, a cup of tea in front of you. And you want to reach out and grab it and take a sit. People with Parkinson's will talk about sitting there, having the thought.
但我们真的不知道为什么只有那些细胞会死亡。当它们死亡时，意味着可用的多巴胺减少了。这似乎与控制刻意或无意识和有意识运动的能力的下降直接相关，即无法让我们的身体做我们想让它做的事情。帕金森病患者会谈论想要，比如，假设你面前有一杯果汁，我不知道，一杯茶。你想伸手去拿它并喝一口。帕金森病患者会谈论坐在那里，有这个想法。
willing their arm, willing, begging their arm to just simply do, like, it's so easy, just move, just move, grab the cup and it just doesn't work. And what's happening is that the command gets stuck in the brain because there aren't enough of those little dopamine messages to shoot the message down and get our body to comply. So when people talk about dopamine and only talk about it in its, you know, in reference to happiness and pleasure, they miss this vital element. And we're going to talk a little bit more about why that's so important in a second. But the final big thing dopamine is implicated in is learning, which makes sense because it is what drives us to seek out novelty and seek out newness because of the anticipation of excitement,
用意志控制他们的手臂，用意志，乞求他们的手臂只是简单地做，就像，这太容易了，只是移动，只是移动，抓住杯子，但它就是不起作用。发生的事情是命令卡在了大脑中，因为没有足够的那些小多巴胺信息来发送信息并让我们的身体服从。所以当人们谈论多巴胺并且只在它（你知道）参考幸福和快乐时谈论它时，他们错过了这个重要的元素。我们稍后会再谈谈为什么这如此重要。但多巴胺涉及的最后一个大事情是学习，这很有道理，因为它驱动我们去寻求新奇和寻求新鲜感，因为对兴奋、
rewards, stimulation, new experiences. It is especially linked to the formation of emotional memories. This was indicated by a 2021 study where they talked about how dopamine, oh my God, what was the study about again? It's basically emotional music triggered dopamine and actually meant that we could memorize lyrics better because of that emotional link. There was also another paper I think published the same year in molecular psychiatry that talks about how dopamine is linked to stronger fear memories, which is funny because our traditional. understanding of dopamine is this happy hormone, you wouldn't think of it as having a role in encoding how we think of fear and things that have hurt us and frightened us and yet terrified us in the past. So this is what we miss when we see dopamine purely through the pleasure lens. The other thing that happens is that a misunderstanding about dopamine can mean that we,
奖励、刺激、新体验的预期。它特别与情绪记忆的形成有关。这在2021年的一项研究中得到了表明，他们谈到了多巴胺，天哪，那项研究到底是关于什么的？它基本上是情绪音乐触发了多巴胺，实际上意味着因为那种情绪联系，我们可以更好地记住歌词。我认为同年在《Molecular Psychiatry》上发表的另一篇论文谈到了多巴胺如何与更强的恐惧记忆联系在一起，这很有趣，因为我们对多巴胺的传统理解是这种快乐激素，你不会认为它在编码我们如何思考恐惧以及过去伤害过我们、吓过我们甚至让我们感到恐惧的事情方面有作用。所以这就是当我们纯粹通过快乐的视角看待多巴胺时所错过的。发生的另一件事是，对多巴胺的误解可能意味着我们，
how do I say this? Like it can be used for pseudoscientific purposes. because dopamine is such like a flashy catch word, any random person can pop it on a Instagram slide or pop it in a video or put it next in a marketing campaign and make us believe that what they are saying is true because dopamine has such a reputation, right? The biggest example of this is, or the biggest example of ways that dopamine can become, Like the ways that dopamine can become pseudoscientific and people can talk about it in an incorrect way is dopamine detoxes. What is a dopamine detox? If you haven't heard about it, basically it is a practice that's been popularized in the last 10 years.
我该怎么说呢？就像它可以被用于伪科学目的。因为多巴胺是一个如此华丽的流行词，任何随机的人都可以把它放在Instagram幻灯片上，或者把它放在视频里，或者把它放在营销活动中，让我们相信他们所说的是真的，因为多巴胺有这样的声誉，对吧？这方面最大的例子是，或者多巴胺可能变得伪科学的最大例子，人们可能以不正确的方式谈论它，那就是多巴胺排毒。什么是多巴胺排毒？如果你没听说过，基本上它是过去10年里流行起来的一种做法。
It was firstly introduced by this man named Dr. Cameron Sipar, I think, Sepath, Dr. Cameron, I'll call him Dr. Cameron. And the premise is that you abstain from easy dopamine activity. with the hopes of reducing your baseline sensitivity to dopamine so that you feel rewarded by less. Basically, if you're addicted to sugar, let's say artificial sugar, going days without artificial sugar, testing yourself control such that when you have artificial sugar again, just a little bit feels as amazing as when you used to have a lot of it. That is the premise of a dopamine detox switched artificial sugar with dopamine.
它最初是由一位名叫Dr. Cameron Sipar（我想是Sepath，Dr. Cameron，我会叫他Dr. Cameron）的人引入的。前提是你戒掉容易获得多巴胺的活动，希望降低你对多巴胺的基准敏感度，这样你就能从更少的事情中感到满足。基本上，如果你对糖上瘾，比如说人造糖，几天不吃人造糖，测试你的自我控制力，这样当你再次吃人造糖时，只需一点点就会感觉像你过去吃很多时一样棒。这就是多巴胺排毒的前提，把人造糖换成多巴胺。
The idea is we can reset our brain and therefore certain compulsive behaviors by essentially starving our brain of easy dopamine. Now, I'm going to call myself out here and I'm going to say, I have
这个想法是我们基本上可以通过让大脑挨饿容易获得的多巴胺来重置我们的大脑，从而重置某些强迫行为。现在，我要在这里自我批评一下，我要说，我
mentioned dopamine detoxes on the podcast before in a very positive light. Specifically, with regards to our smartphones, I read few studies about how interrupting your brain's immediate anticipation of dopamine when you pick up your phone is like essential for breaking an addictive loop. And I have talked about it, but I've recently dug a little bit further into it. And it's not that experts are necessarily opposed
之前在播客上以非常积极的态度提到过“多巴胺排毒”。特别是在我们的智能手机方面，我读过一些研究，关于当你拿起手机时，中断大脑对多巴胺的即时预期对于打破成瘾循环是至关重要的。我谈到过它，但我最近深入挖掘了一下。并不是说专家们一定反对
to these kind of like abstinence stints. They just really disagree with the idea of the use of the term detox. Dopamine detox, detoxifying. Dopamine. Deposifying. Dopamine. Dope. isn't a toxin. It's not something your body needs to be rid of in order to build back up a purer or healthier reserve. As one Harvard article as well in 2020 put it, you also can't fast from a naturally occurring brain chemical. Like if we could deliberately deplete dopamine, we know the outcome of that. Parkinson's, literally, that is what a lack of dopamine, that is what a lack of dopamine, that is what fast depletion of dopamine does. Do you know what I mean? So it's, you actually don't want that. You don't want your brain to be without it. Dopamine definitely does rise in response to
这种禁欲期。他们只是非常不同意使用“排毒”这个词。多巴胺排毒，排毒。多巴胺。排毒。多巴胺。多巴胺不是毒素。它不是你的身体为了建立更纯净或更健康的储备而需要摆脱的东西。正如2020年的一篇哈佛文章所言，你也不能从一种自然产生的脑化学物质中禁食。就像如果我们能故意耗尽多巴胺，我们知道结果是什么。帕金森病，字面上，这就是缺乏多巴胺，这就是缺乏多巴胺，这就是多巴胺快速耗尽所做的事情。你知道我的意思吗？所以，你实际上不想要那个。你不希望你的大脑没有它。多巴胺确实会响应
rewards. The availability of dopamine increases with anticipation and the anticipation of pleasurable activities. But there's no way that you can go into your brain or you can directly influence the level of dopamine available in your brain through behavioral choices. Other than like maybe, maybe diet, but only then in terms of like increasing levels and the availability and the health of your own brain. What's really happening is not with dopamine detoxes, is not that you're increasing sensitivity. It's not that you are literally reducing dopamine levels because that's impossible unless you have a neurodegenerative disease. it's that you're practicing mindfulness.
奖励而上升。多巴胺的可用性随着预期和对愉快活动的预期而增加。但你无法进入你的大脑，或者你无法通过行为选择直接影响大脑中可用的多巴胺水平。除了像可能，可能饮食，但也只是在增加水平和你的大脑的健康和可用性方面。真正发生的事情不是多巴胺排毒，不是你在增加敏感度。不是你在字面上降低多巴胺水平，因为除非你有神经退行性疾病，否则这是不可能的。是你正在练习正念。
That is why dopamine detoxes work. Again, not that they're the right term, but that's why the premise behind them works. A dopamine fast is basically just reasserting control over behaviors that have become manageable because you're finally paying attention to the ways that they become detrimental to your life and the self-control that you may or may not be able to have over them. The results we see of needing less to feel a similar level of reward or gaining control over certain habits is not the depletion or the, it's not that you are asserting control over dopamine.
这就是为什么多巴胺排毒有效。同样，不是说它们是正确的术语，但这就是它们背后的前提有效的原因。多巴胺禁食基本上只是重新确立对已经变得难以管理的行为的控制，因为你终于注意到了它们变得对你的生活有害的方式，以及你可能或可能无法对它们拥有的自我控制力。我们看到的需要更少来感受类似水平的奖励或获得对某些习惯的控制的结果，不是耗尽，或者，不是你在对多巴胺行使控制。
It's a completely different psychological system. What's really happening and what you're really experiencing is executive function and executive control that interrupts a previously enforced loop, behavioral loop. essentially your brain has learnt a very efficient cycle of cue craving action reward you know if you feel slightly uncomfortable if you feel bored anxious undistimulated and you reach for your phone and you receive the reward of that behavior over time the loop becomes automatic i being on my phone makes me happy so i should do it more what a dopamine detox actually does is not you know by abstaining, you're not actually depleting dopamine levels. What it does is just insert conscious awareness back into the equation. Instead of immediately obeying the craving, you pause,
这是一个完全不同的心理系统。真正发生的事情和你真正体验到的是执行功能和执行控制，它中断了一个先前强制的循环，行为循环。基本上你的大脑已经学会了一个非常有效的循环：线索、渴望、行动、奖励。你知道，如果你感到稍微不舒服，如果你感到无聊、焦虑、没有刺激，你就去拿手机，你就得到了那个行为的奖励。随着时间的推移，循环变得自动化，即“我在手机上让我快乐，所以我应该多做”。多巴胺排毒实际上所做的不是（你知道）通过禁欲，你并没有真正耗尽多巴胺水平。它所做的只是将有意识的觉知重新插入等式中。而不是立即服从渴望，你暂停，
you observe it, you tolerate it, and every time you do that, you strengthen the brain systems involved in self-regulation, and you weaken the automatic reinforcement cycle that was running unchecked before. So that's really what's happening in these detoxes. This is what's happening when we talk about being able to control dopamine. And that is the true psychology behind dopamine that we get wrong. More dopamine doesn't make you happier. Something triggering dopamine doesn't mean it will become addictive. The reason certain drugs or activities are addictive isn't because they spike dopamine
你观察它，你忍受它，每次你这样做，你都会加强参与自我调节的大脑系统，并削弱之前未受检查的自动强化循环。所以这才是这些排毒中真正发生的事情。这就是当我们谈论能够控制多巴胺时发生的事情。这就是我们弄错的关于多巴胺的真正心理学。更多的多巴胺不会让你更快乐。某事触发多巴胺并不意味着它会变得上瘾。某些药物或活动令人上瘾的原因不是因为它们激增多巴胺
and give us something that's only a small part of it. It's often because they take away or mask a different, more unpleasant sensation. And so our body has learnt that the presence of, of this thing makes us feel better. Dopamine's role in that is that it just helps you learn that association. It's not responsible for the end feeling. And it's definitely not something that you can detox, control, and dopamine certainly isn't this bad, addictive thing that you need to avoid.
并给我们一些东西，那只是其中的一小部分。通常是因为它们带走了或掩盖了另一种更不愉快的感受。所以我们的身体已经学会了这种东西的存在让我们感觉更好。多巴胺在其中的作用是它只是帮助你学习那种关联。它不对最终的感觉负责。而且它绝对不是你需要排毒、控制的东西，多巴胺当然也不是你需要避免的这种坏的、令人上瘾的东西。
What we can take from this, I think, my God, look at me. I'm so, what we can take from this, I sound like, lecturer, but what we can take from this is just a really important shift in how we understand motivation. Most of us assume that we are driven by the reward itself, the promotion, the text back, the dopamine hit from social media, from impulse shopping, from dessert achievement, but psychology and neuroscience show that what actually drives behavior far more powerfully is the anticipation of the reward. It is the possibility of pleasure, not always the pleasure itself that keeps us moving. And this, knowing this can change how we motivate ourselves.
我们可以从中得到什么，我想，天哪，看看我。我太，我们可以从中得到什么，我听起来像个讲师，但我们可以从中得到的是我们如何理解动机的一个非常重要的转变。我们大多数人假设我们是由奖励本身驱动的，晋升、回复短信、来自社交媒体的多巴胺冲击、来自冲动购物、来自甜点成就，但心理学和神经科学表明，真正更强大地驱动行为的是对奖励的预期。是快乐的可能性，并不总是快乐本身让我们保持前进。而且这个，知道这一点可以改变我们如何激励自己。
If anticipation is what energizes you or energizes us, then creating small moments of reward is better than large, massive ones. Goals work better when they feel just within reach. Breaking down tasks and giving yourself microrewards along the way is going to improve your motivation to carry through. Habits become easier when you're going to. there's some sense of emotional payoff and there's some anticipation attached to their achievement. That is how we can use this new understanding of dopamine to actually apply principles of reward and motivation and anticipation to our lives and just get more stuff done. So there you go. That is the end of our little mini bonus episode on the psychology or the
如果预期是让你充满活力或让我们充满活力，那么创造小的奖励时刻比大的、巨大的奖励时刻更好。当目标感觉就在触手可及的地方时，它们效果更好。分解任务并在过程中给自己微奖励将提高你坚持下去的动力。当你去的时候，习惯变得更容易。有一些情感回报感，并且它们的实现附带了一些预期。这就是我们如何利用这种对多巴胺的新理解来真正应用奖励、动机和预期的原则到我们的生活中，并完成更多的事情。所以就这样。这就是我们关于心理学或
debunked psychology of dopamine. I hope that you've enjoyed it. I hope that it's given you some fun facts to share at the dinner table or with your friends. I think I said this in our last episode, but now you can be that annoying person who, like, corrects people when they use the word dopamine wrong. It's satisfying the first time and then you start to realize that people don't like you as much. But I just think it's good for our own self-knowledge and our own self-awareness. So I hope you enjoyed this episode. Remember, we have a bunch more episodes just like this, debunking popular psychology myths. We did one long. week on the myth of the frontal lobe developing at 25. If you want more fun history behind
被揭穿的多巴胺心理学的迷你奖励剧集的结尾。我希望你喜欢它。我希望它给你提供了一些可以在餐桌上或与朋友分享的有趣事实。我想我在上一集中说过，但现在你可以成为那个讨厌的人，当人们错误地使用“多巴胺”这个词时，你会纠正他们。第一次很满足，然后你开始意识到人们不像以前那样喜欢你了。但我只是认为这对我们自己的自我知识和自我意识有好处。所以我希望你喜欢这一集。记住，我们还有很多像这样的剧集，揭穿流行的心理学误区。我们做过一周关于25岁时前额叶发育的误区的节目。如果你想要更多有趣的心理学原则背后的历史，
psychological principles, that is an amazing one to listen to. The link between, here's a spoiler. We talk about Leonardo DiCaprio. We talk about the death penalty. And we talk about pseudoscience. So if you want to understand how all of those are linked up, great episode for you to listen to, Of course, all of our regular episodes are now on Netflix if you want to watch, not this one, because this is just an audio episode for my OG audio listeners, but any number of our other episodes are on Netflix if you prefer to watch a video podcast. What else have we got for you? Subsdack, we've got Instagram.
那是一个非常值得听的节目。之间的联系，这里有一个剧透。我们谈论Leonardo DiCaprio。我们谈论死刑。我们谈论伪科学。所以如果你想了解所有这些是如何联系在一起的，这对你来说是一个很棒的剧集。当然，我们所有的常规剧集现在都在Netflix上，如果你想看的话，不是这一集，因为这只是给我OG音频听众的音频剧集，但如果你更喜欢看视频播客，我们的其他任何剧集都在Netflix上。我们还有什么给你们的？Subsdack，我们有Instagram。
All of the links will be down below. But until next time, thank you for listening. Be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself, and we will talk very, very soon. There was no... thing inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave.
所有的链接都在下面。但直到下次，谢谢收听。保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔，我们很快很快就会再谈。那些眼睛里什么都没有。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。邪恶，醒醒。我是那个目睹了Crevette和DePippo谋杀案的人。Anthony DePippo没有表现出任何悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得泰然自若。我说，我没有罪。我会把真相带进坟墓。
Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Bone Valley》中的《Devil's Quarry》。快乐是必不可少的，但它也难以捉摸，但现在有一种新的、令人兴奋的方式来开启您通往更快乐生活的旅程，《Joy 101》。这是一个由我，Hoda Kotby主持的新播客。如果您渴望获得灵感来最大化您的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的广播聊天。打开您免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。
Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby is presented. by CBS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born.
搜索《Joy 101》并立即收听。《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》由CBS赞助。每个人都视我为一名足球运动员，但首先，我是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何处理问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。
This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tornandez, and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed.
这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。只是关于活着的意义的诚实对话。我是Javier Tornandez，请在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learning to Be Human》。这里有一件事不应该像现在这样复杂，那就是移除种族主义雕像。
And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akila Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority black city in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这里有一件事应该比现在容易得多，那就是在原处放置一个新的。我是Akila Hughes，《Rebel Spirit》第二季就是关于这两件事的。当我看着这些雕像被拆除时，我在想，我在一个大多数是黑人的城市长大，那里对奴隶主的致敬比对被奴役的人的致敬更多，这意味着什么。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Rebel Spirit》第二季。
June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams' Parts, podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like, so much more to do. Like, Prince, he dropped like 30 albums. We dropped like five right now. Like, that's the rate we gotta be going.
六月是黑人音乐月，在《Drink Chams》播客中，我们正在与文化界最热门的人物交谈，比如Sway Lee。你意识到你有多传奇了吗？我很感激。我看到了，但我心想，伙计，我还有很多事情要做。就像Prince，他发行了大约30张专辑。我们现在才发行了五张。就像，这就是我们必须达到的速度。
Yeah, that's a good attitude. No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations. Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，那是一个很好的态度。无论什么时代，《Drink Chams》都会为您带来最大牌的人物和最直白的对话。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听来自Black Effect Podcast Network的《Drink Chams》。这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是人类制作。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。